violent clashes are sandals taksim
squares protesters and police face off
two weeks ago it started out as a small
demo by secularists and conservationists
over plans to redevelop gezi Park
mushroomed into a countrywide protest
thousands have been injured in the
violence global condemnation of police
brutality and disregarded basic human
rights also so protest outside
parliament on Tuesday the Green Party
invited representatives from the Turkish
movement to Strasbourg I think it's very
important that we get people from Turkey
to talk to us here to talk about what's
happening we stumble and also other
cities of Turkey and I think it's
absolutely vital that the European
Parliament strongly condemns the police
violence the tear gassing of protesters
of people who are just standing up for a
couple of tree for their right to take
part in decision making and to strongly
say this is not worthy of an EU
candidate country telling tales of
violence and solidarity member eleo bora
who has been involved since the
beginning joined the debate via skype
after the usage of violence against
peaceful people the return also became
to protest the violence against freedom
of expression people then started to
express themselves on matters that they
think they couldn't had the chance to
express before at the plenary emmy pays
debate to the situation in Turkey with
Catherine Ashton the High Representative
for the union for foreign affairs and
security policy passing a resolution
condemning the excessive use of force by
police back in Turkey in an effort to
placate protesters the AK Party said it
would consider a referendum on the
redevelopment of gezi Park but will that
be enough if you stop the violence is
not enough to say that they have changed
the system we have also to hoga doing is
it whether the arrogant government is
the long run going the right direction
in order to meet the values of a
European Union all we have to develop
ideas for a new type of relationship
with Turkey which is not a membership
relationship